what do you want to rap about
refrigerator
you said that with the least enthusiasm
i've ever encountered for anything ever
just refrigerator yeah um do you own a
refrigerator
yeah what good
good someone over there doing the great
is your refrigerator running joke
classic banter cool refrigerator that is
a good suggestion
um let's come to these four tables oh
there's a bunch
if you're in this little square here
what you want to rap about
real estate wow so far refrigerators and
real estate
this is the most exciting rap i've ever
heard let's
crack this open a little bit are you
involved in real estate
one of your friends is well okay that's
all right what specifically
about real estate would you like us to
focus on
real estate agents are always on their
phones okay real estate agents always
being on their phones
refrigerators let's come to the back of
the room uh you know where you are if
you're the back room on the back wall or
in the back corner what's your rap about
oh there were two at the same time so
let's let's break them apart what were
they
wait why not two of you at the same time
didn't say space force
they did okay and what was the other one
was it zombie something
zombie apocalypse okay space force
combating the zombie apocalypse that's
what we'll combine those to be
space force combat in the zombie
apocalypse refrigerator
and uh real estate agents always be on
their phones let's come to
the kind of those two rows in the middle
of the room here what do you want to
repair
waterfall yeah do you like are you a fan
of waterfalls
yeah name one
well that's just because someone there
said it right
what's the what's the largest waterfall
in the world
yeah it's victoria and they're not
alexandria about you i'm just very
excited i'm going i'm going to see alex
go and see victoria falls in a month and
a half it's going to be fun yeah
i'm going to do comedy in botswana and
then going up there and you don't care
about that right
um waterfalls um and
guys front two rows here i mean this
front row is missing half of them uh if
you would like if you were here what
would you like a rap about
what was that easy
okay for those who don't know eze one of
the the founding members of the seminal
rap group nwa who died of aids
um it's it's a great way to end out that
rock okay
this uh this then lovely people of the
comedy and magic club to close out the
show
it's a freestyle that's a made upon the
spot based italian those suggestions the
suggestions to remind you
easy e waterfalls refrigerators
real estate agents always been on their
phones and space force destroying a
zombie apocalypse
what are you saying do you just keep
repeating space force when i say it
why what what do you like so much about
the space force
oh you just keep saying space balls
wasn't that that movie about space that
was
i guess funny at the time but upon
re-watching is disappointing
he says a sentence that is applicable to
every comedy from the 1980s
um cool it's like you watch the
breakfast club you're like this is
really fun you're watching now you're
like oh no it's
kind of [ __ ] and uh has a real rapey
undertone right
sorry if it's your favorite movie this
is going to be a freestyle about all
those things don't worry it won't be
anywhere near as atrociously bad as
you're expecting a privately educated
middle class white boy to be
let's drop that beat let's have some fun
i got you a nice chill beat because this
is the early show so i thought we should
take it smooth and take it cool um
yeah we'll start with yours trying to
always flip in all the homes got a real
estate agent and he's flipping through
his phone got an
iphone maybe a samsung 20 apps on the
display yes he's got plenty
picking up the calls where do you begin
press the green answer button now you're
on to red fin maybe
zoopla or other type of housing market
pay attention to me
when my house is on the market i started
a fight i mean i rip it out his hand
i say i'm trying to sell my abode you
understand i don't want to foreclose or
lose the mortgage
i've got to live here with my wife and
my four kids but he doesn't even care
he's a slimy fella he gets his old phone
out a big
antenna like a phone from wall street in
the past in the 80s space force laser
blast
raining down if the zombies are coming
to town walking dead filmed in atlanta
they were found
sheriff rick grimes saving it every time
putting his whole wife and son life on
the line
but if he had a spaceship in space they
could hit a zombie brain right the back
of his face
like shawn at the dead cutting off the
head it's the reason every morning that
i got our bed because i love spaceships
and i love to slay [ __ ]
if i've got a chainsaw then i'm gonna
chase it down the street
the zombie the walking dead i'm like get
down there
be deceased instead zombies coming from
haitian folklore
if you didn't know it maybe read a book
bore and if you want a cool little fact
check it out later i put three on in my
refrigerator it means that it keeps it
so damn cold a lot of refrigerators so
damn old
from the 1950s in our home you can
protect yourself from nuclear bombs
indiana jones did that in the movie that
they remade
crystal skull put the fridge on display
i reach right there
to the back i find an old peach at the
side that has turned black is horrible
the flesh
is rotten cause i've forgotten it
refrigerator yeah people say that kind
of [ __ ]
for the environment putting holes in the
ozone but we still got one in each one
of our homes i'll be going down the
breezy beach i'm in compton maybe long
beach with easy e
wearing a black cap and maybe all black
clothes he hates dr dre that's a fact we
all know
bad boy records had a big damn feud easy
he's like the songs were always improved
he goes wrote for dre
but then they had a split and still
somehow train managed to stack the hits
of a really good producer but not as
good as rhyming
easy great rapper really put the time in
but sadly passed
due to hiv complications if i'm going to
the botswana nation i travel
north east up to cho bay park and then
zimbabwe have a real art victoria falls
so long and it's strange or maybe in
venezuela the tall one called angel
falls that's the highest
and the widest in two visit all the
other falls what you're gonna do
if it's in a video game go through the
water there's usually a treasure test i
thought that i ought to know
that by now waterfalls i'm in a barrel
i'm falling over the precipice
straight and narrow i keep it cool and i
somehow survive
another indiana jones reference that i
tried because harrison ford he was the
actor
in the fugitive then he did that there
he jumped off the waterfall technically
not in the plan because it wasn't a
waterfall it was an
outlet from a dam but it still works
there you go
you